my guest tonight very funny comedian
and an actor who stars in the hbo series
curb your enthusiasm his new podcast
may i elaborate daily wisdom from jb
smoove is streaming now
please welcome our really good friend b
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
smooth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello how are you
look at this man yeah this is fantastic
it's nice it reminds me of like a a
nursing
convention or something like that see
it's they all got masks on but they
still make a lot of noise
it it is not dim the enthusiasm all
these damn surgeons out here i love it
look at me
you know uh it is so nice to see you so
nice of you to stop by
you look absolutely incredible you know
what
i put this outfit on and i always uh
confirm with my wife if i look cool
you know and she was like hmm she gave
me a
hmm yeah she said i like it
but do you see i love when people say do
you
she said it's so do you yeah
she stopped herself do you yeah and i'm
doing me baby come on now
that's funny that's funny
hey i got to tell you i call i call this
i call this the half heisman it's like
this
that's
add that to your repertoire man yeah
it's funny if you're long and lean
i'm no offense you're long and lean
you're long and lean man when you're
long and lean like that you do the half
heisman
tip like one tippy toe like this like
this handling pocket
stand stand the [ __ ] up first of all
stand up
and look away from people like like
someone calling you over there
i'm like a frightened bird
you know i don't it doesn't work for me
i think it works for you
yeah you know are you excited so many
people are excited that this
this man it's 15 months of this pandemic
everyone's excited about different
things
restaurants are opening up are you
excited for restaurants
i am so excited for restaurants man
conan andy i just love them i think uh
it's we need to get them back on their
feet
you know and i just love going out and
seeing people
having a good time and talking and
mingling you know and see me
i go to restaurants see i'm a
connoisseur of fine food
see i i don't i don't read menus i i
haven't read a menu in 25 years
you don't look at all at the menu a menu
is for amateurs that's amateur stuff
anybody can read a damn menu i go to the
restaurant i have my wife
the menu so dead baby get what the hell
you want see and i sit back
and when the waiter comes over he says
what do you guys have i said give my
lady what she wants
and i'm going to have the special yeah
you always at you always ask for the
special always
and then i say i'm gonna have a special
then when he begins to tell me the
special i say
shut the [ __ ] up
this is this is your night it's not
about him this is your night
they say shut the [ __ ] up i didn't ask
you what the special was i said that
bring me the special yes
see now that that takes yeah yeah the
pressure is on the chef in that
in in that kitchen yeah to impress me
yeah yeah yeah
okay i think you could tone it down a
little bit
no that's all i'm saying you could tone
it down same attitude but just take it
down a little bit oh man
no now that's what amateurs see
when everybody turns when you say shut
the [ __ ] up
i didn't tell you to tell me the special
i said to bring me the special
yeah listen yeah
you know i i thought you had gone too
far and then you said it again and i
realized you were pitch perfect
hey let me tell you something let me
tell you something
you are there to have a wonderful night
you know and people got to realize that
this guy
means business he wants that chef to be
on his best
yeah he wants the best meal tonight he's
been locked up on his pandemic and he's
just getting back out man i do cool
stuff too so i like i like to cross my
leg right so yeah sometimes
and what i do sometimes is i i'll cross
my leg over
the table like this well no you can't no
jb you can't do that that's
you can't do that no it's working and
then and then
i put my leg over a candle like this
and i hold it there until my sock starts
to smoke okay a little bit
and then i put it down like that i don't
see the point of that at all
that's just that's just pure idiocy
people respect that conan
they respect that yeah just like
question lego over just like that
just like just hold it there you know
how many
you know how many single socks i have
now i know
i have ruined so many right socks man
jamie i got to ask you something you did
something recently
that it shocked me you shot something
for shark week
oh and i can't believe this i i have not
seen it yet
but i'm told that you swam with sharks
which sounds insane to me
you don't fear sharks conan
in the aquatic do you want me to shut
the [ __ ] up is that what you want shut
the [ __ ] up
i just you know what bugs me when you
doubt me when you start doubting me you
had the smug face
you started down i don't think i was
being smug you smug you're a smuggler
you're a smuggler
you smug the [ __ ] out of me
i was concerned andy be real now well i
just think he lives in fear
yes so thank you yeah yeah yeah
you're right you're you're swimming with
sharks you weren't scared at all
no i was not you know what i tell you
this much i am a big part of the aquatic
world you understand
and i've been i've been there for years
what are you doing my scene you're about
every
oceanographer you're a big part of the
aquatic world what do you
read what are you talking about
i'm commonly known uh to all species of
underwater creatures as the black
dolphin
you're the black dolphin i've been to
black
see there you go again
i am simply looking for clarification
you sir are the black dolphins i am the
black dolphin okay and
and see when i go underwater this was
like me
returning to my roots you understand
right
it's me returning to my roots okay um
you know it's as if it's that this
didn't happen but it's as if
i was birthed and you know how you you
see movies where they put a baby in a
little basket
and they sent him down the river and
then some other family found him
finds the baby in the basket oh my baby
in a basket and raised that child
yeah i was put in a boat a little
inflatable boat put in the ocean
and i floated through the ocean was
found by some
friendly very nice dolphins and they
raised me
as the black dolphin you're the black
dolphin no
ben i'll tell you something man it is
the most amazing feeling in the world to
be
underwater and and all you hear
coming i'm telling you all you hear is
your breathing
it's the most amazing feeling in the
world you know and when i get to space
you don't know what i say when i get to
space i'm gonna say this [ __ ]
feel like the ocean
that's what i'm gonna say same thing
same thing
yeah and now we'll tell you one thing oh
the convenience of it all
cause who has time to keep going back up
to that boat
to take a piss who has time so
while you're underwater just let it go
i i don't i don't think here i don't
think you're the first one
yeah yeah no it's amazing i understand
it's an amazing feeling
knowing you can piss on yourself and
there's no repercussions
there's no stain there's no stain so you
want to your dream is to piss urinate on
yourself with no repercussions
oh man i was underwater man you have
strange aspirations
look when i'm underwater and my flippers
are moving like this
i'm like this
that's how you move okay wait a minute
superman
so do you do you i mean jb are you
wearing that hat when you're underwater
[Applause]
you just give you know and and i gotta i
gotta show love
to the sharks man cause they showed me
love you know they didn't have to do
that
you know a dolphin shows up you know at
this at this [ __ ] reef
a dolphin just shows up out of nowhere
you know they show
so much respect for the black dolphin
yeah
and i know i i appreciate that yeah and
right now i just want to give a big
shout out out there to my people out
there
you know who you are the reef shark the
tiger shark
sand shark much appreciation goes out to
you
you show me love like that you show me
mad love
no but i tell you man it is if you
haven't done it yet if anyone has
anybody ever done it before
it is the most before i'm telling you
before you jump
in you are terrified yeah but for some
reason there
is this calm these sharks were swimming
around
myself and brad paisley we did we
you know we do well i mean i don't even
think you needed to say that yeah no we
all we we the black dolphin hangs out
with brad paisley of course he does
of course he does yeah have you ever
paisley's probably the white gulf
yeah see here's my thing here's my thing
you know i know who i am i communicate
with these animals i go
[Music]
[Applause]
that's dolphin court yeah that's dolphin
talk so
so so see you you have to like i know in
the black dolphin
who are you
in this in this beautiful world of
underwater world well you tell me you're
the expert what
what underwater uh creature am i i got
them i got them all ready okay well you
are
what you're a red snapper
come on man come on man red snapper now
see
now here's the difference between me and
you yeah i can i can drive
under under the water amongst the sharks
yeah and the sperm whales and the blue
whales
you see i can live down there because
they understand me they accept me
into their circles but you you're a red
snapper
you gonna end up on somebody's [ __ ]
plate
right soldermash
guess what guess what i'll be we're
going to bring this full circle i'll be
the special yeah
put there you know you're just messing
you're the best i got to ask you
something
i want to make sure that i mention this
you have a podcast called may i
elaborate
daily wisdom from jb's move and it's
such
a wonderful service because you people
can tune in it's not a long podcast
every day you're putting out
great wisdom for people to get them
through the day and
you're probably who knows you might be
saving lives out there it's amazing
no we we help people every day conan
i'm only doing this podcast because
people need help
we're trying to get back on our feet
here man i'm trying to help people i'm
giving people concrete advice
you know and here's what i do i take
a simple affirmation and people
don't understand these affirmations
sometimes they get confused
by what they what they mean now they
have one i talk about
we got one called roller coaster it's
absolutely amazing i just elaborated on
this amazing quote and i talk about how
uh when you ride a your life is like a
roller coaster
you when you get in the roller coaster
you go up this hill
and just click click click click click
click click click click click you talk
to your friend this is going to be great
oh my god
i love this roller coaster click click
click click click click
click when you get to the top of that
roller coaster
that entire ride is your life
your life is a roller coaster so always
say to people you enjoy that ride
enjoy that life enjoy your ride on that
roller coaster your life is a complete
now some roller coasters have a loop the
loop
maybe you got somebody pregnant or you
know
or you asked me to
you
[Laughter]
lost a job yeah or something [ __ ]
happened you know but it's just a
loop-de-loop
yeah you still got momentum moments home
you still
keep moving that one click click click
and that one drop
carries you through your whole entire
life so i say enjoy your [ __ ] life
until those clicks until those click
click clicks
become tick tick ticks
whoo i know [ __ ] no goddamn right
hey don't get me started i make all
these [ __ ] cry i make
everybody cry i'm telling you so see
i'm not sure i went along with that but
whatever yeah yeah i mean they seem
happy
you damn right see that's how deep we go
sometimes but we do it we do it in that
you go that deep oh we go deep we want
you to
laugh and we want you to understand
these affirmations we want you to apply
them to your life
see i'm a fixer i fix people yeah
i want to say something in all sincerity
okay
because um yeah you're an insane man uh
but i want to say something in all the
sincerity which is i remember
i it was very important to me to get
certain people to come here as we wrap
up this uh
phase of the show and i i really wanted
you here
very glad that you could be here and
i'll tell you why uh you guys may not
know this but
jb was a writer on saturday live yes and
the first time i met you
we uh cast you in something uh
and you were a writer you weren't known
at all you weren't famous you did this
sketch for us you were hilarious the
minute you came out people laughed
then we started saying every time let's
get jb let's get
we kept pulling you downstairs from
starting out live you would do stuff for
us
you were always money in the bank
hilarious
hilarious and then you went off and
your career has completely blown up and
you're one of the funniest people i know
and i
couldn't be happier for you and you're
such a nice person and it felt
this is nice full circle like let's just
get together
and uh you know these last couple of
days and and see jb smooth because
you're the real deal you're a fantastic
guy
conan let me tell you something man and
you know i say this
with the utmost of love and respect for
you man you have been
absolutely an amazing piece of my
comedy journey and it's very important
that people understand that
this dude right here he works hard man
this
dude this dude yeah
and and
when you find genuine people in this
business man you you
you take it man and you take it anytime
this man needs me
i'm looking forward to your next
adventure man i can't wait to see where
you're laying
and i i told you what i was thinking
about you should you should have had a
uh
where you're going at like a network or
like people do those
gender reveals
was what ginger a gender gender revealed
how gender related ever pink or or
blue and and they pop the [ __ ] bubble
and it'd be a
it's a girl you know we're having a girl
whatever yeah you should have a reveal
it should be like a bam and it's it's a
cooking show no yeah
yeah whatever oh corning that's perfect
for you it's no i i can't cook at all i
would be
i hate i would hate that that would be a
terrible thing
well is it up to me do i get to decide
or is it revealed to me at the same time
you're a morning sportscaster [ __ ]
that's bad
i love it no that's bad i don't know
like a grab bag full of [ __ ]
like you know i shouldn't know that
would be great a reality show where i
don't know
what show i'm going to do next and it's
random and it's revealed to me
it's chosen by a medical test yeah
some kind of medical test yes yes yes
yes i love it so you do fix things i do
fix things
here's what i don't want to happen i
don't want your punk ass
to get up here your last show right
and and [ __ ] tears start welling up
in your ass okay
and i know i know they're coming up
because the tears fill your body up from
the waist up
what are you talking about you're
telling me you do not want any cheers on
the final night i'm telling you it's
like when you hold the fart in
you're in that [ __ ] you hope when you
hold a farting
you just farted inside your own [ __ ]
body
so right now you you are
crying inside your own body
so no crying no crying no all right you
leave this
[ __ ] defiant defiant defiant to the end
[ __ ] you leave you make sure he does
this
be fired okay leave here defiant
you you you have done so much amazing so
many amazing damn shows man
i want you to be content in what the
[ __ ] you have accomplished
and i want you to leave this
[ __ ]
to buy it i want you to take like
you you have a car a vehicle it's not a
real car
it's your vehicle you've been driving
this vehicle for a long ass time
it's gotten you that same [ __ ]
vehicle made your ass run from [ __ ]
new york all the way to l.a remember
that time
[Laughter]
yeah in the desert in a [ __ ] desert
all that [ __ ] what's that that's that
forest gusher
okay so so i will leave defiant
and confident you take this metaphor and
you run with this [ __ ]
you take one [ __ ] foot right
you swear on them put the foot down
swear
so much i got to get this i got to get
this through to you put your foot down
put your foot down yeah okay
now you're driving the car yeah
okay yeah take one foot and put that one
foot on the brake
right yep hit the other foot and put on
the gas yeah
this is how my dad drives yeah
push down push down on that brake yeah
and push down on that gas
oh whoa burning rubber you're damn right
yeah
i want you to leave here defiantly
like i did what i came to do and i'm
out this [ __ ]
all right now when you hold your foot in
that gas yeah
yeah yeah you do this do this you win
i'm gonna do it first you gotta you
gotta
when you leave you've gotta do this all
right go i'm out this [ __ ]
i'm out this [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh